in 2016 that outfit [ __ ] banged the
long shirt and the tightest [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I watch your [ __ ] [ __ ] show dude
Matt Chris huge fan of the show thank
you that's dope um I was gonna you guys
are great I want to make this quick I
only got one question for you and it's
and it's this are my pants too tight
they look cool like is my shirt too long
boy or does this does this fit [ __ ]
schmack you know what I mean is this
fire let me know please I value your
guys's opinions yeah please let me know
bro this guy honestly that outfit is
[ __ ] in 2006. this is a great video in
2016 that outfit [ __ ] banged the long
shirt and the tightest [ __ ] [ __ ] the pan
the pants that tight I never liked it
looks like they're painted on uh
particularly tight I like tight pants I
wear tight pants some of them are too
tight I'm going to be honest those look
a bit too tight it is a little weird
though because you have uh tight pants
and a loose long shirt look a literally
look a little bit too much like a bell
you know what I mean right right if you
just [ __ ] up here like if you're just
like this will go ding ding ding
um yeah it's too it's too much man I
think but that's your style you got the
long dangly cross earring you know I
definitely said I wanted to do that and
you copied it from me but no no I've
been wanting to do that forever oh
George Michael no no no like I watch
dude you're caught up so I feel like um
uh keep the earring
tailor the shirt and uh get a little bit
of bag also baggy jeans are kind of the
thing to do now right what it is shin by
the way is that right baggy pants or the
thing now yeah like jinkos remember
jinkos yeah dude I had a pair of jinkos
I was I never ever cooler than when I
wore jinkos dude yeah I I don't I need
to get bag of your pants I have one pair
of baggy pants and I don't really wear
them too much baggy I'm not in a baggie
I'm in the loose but not least I mean
baggy shirts and [ __ ] puffy ass [ __ ]
jackets baggy ass sweaters way in baggy
pants not for me well but that's what's
in look at go to Justin Bieber's
Instagram you'll see well guess who
doesn't want to follow Justin Bieber's
style well I do I want to follow Haley
beaver style no [ __ ] that's why I wrote
those big [ __ ] Balenciaga things I
want some Haley Bieber [ __ ] I want to
follow her dad's style Stephen now we're
talking is my dad or her Uncle Stephen
Baldwin is Haley Baldwin Bieber's dad
he's great he got a baby shark a grandpa
shark tattoo on his channel Grampy shark
dude [ __ ] follow Stephen Baldwin uh
on Instagram Stephen in Baldwin seven
the guy is now a [ __ ] man of God yep
you could say just like me uh as I would
actually be an understatement as a man
of God he has found God the other
[ __ ] Baldwin boys they all just like
they all went yeah all in different
directions you know
um and Stephen went the direction of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ all right
[Music]